Kathie's in california hi Kathy how are
you hi game I'm well thank you thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up well I'm I'm 65 I lost my
husband three years ago and we weren't
quite done planning for our retirement
um I feel like we were in pretty good
shape but I lost he lost his income
stream we had a business together and he
was the broker so that went away I'm
done
in looking through your steps I've
completed one three and six but two I
have about thirty thousand in debt and
I'm on Social Security now but your
home's paid for yes what's the thirty
thousand that twenty is credit card in
ten is a time sure we bought two months
before he passed are you using the
timeshare do you need to get rid of it I
do use it but the fees and maintenance
as you know are increasing and I'd like
to get rid of it
it's eye contact timeshare exit team
timeshare exit team that we endorse them
for getting rid of a timeshare and
they're the best people in the business
for getting rid of one and it'll cost
you some money but it gets rid of the
problem and it'll get rid of it yeah I
don't get rid of the debt too in the
process so that's something look at now
how much do you have in your nest egg I
have two hundred and thirty eight K in
mutual funds and 131 in an annuity and
about fifty thousand in the bank cool
okay I would turn the timeshare over the
timeshare exit team and I'd write a
check and pay off the credit cards out
of the bank money really yeah I leaves
you thirty thousand in the bank you're
okay you got to have million dollars yet
happening in dollars above that in your
annuity and in your 401 K here all right
and it's op up the stupid credit cards
now you got to stop using them okay I
know I'm trying to get on every dollar
right I'm working on it but I haven't
finished
filling in the blanks yeah it's the one
that's ten minutes if you just lean into
it you can do it the what kind of a
business did you all have now mortgage
lending oh he was the mortgage broker
licensed in California Yasim which is a
process okay and you were working in
that business yes then I still work part
time doing the same thing processing but
you know it's nowhere near what what we
were bringing in sure sure
well the good news is you got you're
still young you got a lot of energy you
can still do a do that for a while could
even do it full-time if you wanted to to
beef your budget up and not touch your
nest egg but your house is paid for and
after today you don't have any dad true
I feels pretty good it does it felt
really good when I paid off the house
yeah folder sold the previous house a
big house and bought a smaller one so
let's make sure the the annuity is in a
a good variable annuity and is invested
in good mutual funds and growing if it's
not we need to do some work there and
the same with the 401k the out the other
retirement section let's make sure those
are in good mutual funds and they're
growing but that half a million dollars
you're 65 when it's 72 if you don't
touch it'll be a million dollars if it's
invested like we teach you to invest it
and so just let it double it'll double
about every seven years and so jump in
there with one of our smart Wester pros
as well if you don't have an investment
broker that's got you in some good
mutual funds there so that that money is
growing and you know you you're in
pretty good shape I mean there's no
struggle here and I'd write a check
today be down to 30,000 I wouldn't worry
about the ten on the timeshare let's
turn that over to Thomas your exit team
click on smart Wester at Dave Ramsey
comm click on smart mister pro and I'll
tell you what let's get you let's get
you into Financial Peace University it
sounds like that this stuff is like you
need to get somebody to walk with you
and help you get things in order and in
control to give you some peace and I'll
do that for you you're starting over
after the loss of your husband so hold
on
Kelly will pick up we'll get you signed
as a gift